Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Achtung!
Nicht im Tor!
Kein Tor! Oder doch? Jetzt was entscheidet der Linienöchter? Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit.
Aber du könntest es Raba nennen.
Ich hörte davon.
Weißt du, was das mit Raba Leipzig auf sich hat?
Nein.
Das ist die Art und Weise, wie ich diesen Verein bezeichne. Angefangen eher als Witz, aber inzwischen aus tiefer Überzeugung, weil ich den Marketingaspekt nicht ganz so geil finde und den damit so ein bisschen humoristisch unterbreche.
Ich sag dir aber was, wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf. Also die RB Leipzig Diskussion, die möchte ich auch nicht aufmachen. Raba Leipzig, die möchte ich auch nicht aufmachen, weil sie, glaube ich…
Die haben wir auch schon geführt. Tribünengespräch Nr.
8, 5, 5 Stunden. Es gibt auch gute Literatur dazu. Aber ich versuche, wenn ich keine Vorgabe vom Sender bekomme, auch die stadiengebrandeten Namen nicht zu nennen. Wenn ich wirklich mal dazu komme, dass ich Mannschaften aus Ligen kommentiere, die Werksmannschaften sind oder die einfach einen Sponsor im Namen haben dürfen, auch dann nenne ich den nicht. Ich bin nicht dazu gezwungen, weil der Sender mich dafür bezahlt, dass ich Werbung machen muss. Und selbst dann habe ich mich schon unbeliebt gemacht, indem ich das nicht tue, weil ich das nicht einsehe. Schlicht und ergreifend. Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, wie die Stadien in Nürnberg und Co. heißen. Wir haben neulich mal diskutiert, Augsburger Stadion. Ich weiß es nicht und es ist mir auch völlig egal. Das ist nicht meine Aufgabe. Ich bin Journalist und ich mache das nicht.
Und wie oft kommt es vor, dass du gezwungen wirst vom Sender oder dass es da mal so ne indirekte oder direkte Ansage gibt?
Gott sei Dank sehr selten. Weil die Sender im Grunde – das ist so ein journalistischer Krodex, wenn du so willst, um es mal ganz hoch zu hängen, dass wir das nicht tun. Weil einfach Werbung und Inhalt voneinander klar getrennt werden müssen. Das ist das eigentliche Verbrechen an der Pressefreiheit in Deutschland.
Genau. Aber trotzdem gibt es ja sehr viele Kollegen, die gerade auch Red Bull Leipzig sagen und denen ist ganz offensichtlich auch total egal.
Ich habe ein Beispiel, ich nenne jetzt keinen Namen oder Sender oder Medium. Da habe ich die Frage an den LDS, also das ist dann der Leiter der Sendung, habe gesagt, wie verfahren wir hinsichtlich dessen? Und dann sagt der, ja wieso, und dann haben wir so ein bisschen diskutiert und dann kommt der andere Kollege ums Eck und sagt, ja wieso, die haben denn doch dafür bezahlt, wieso sagen wir das nicht?
Haben die dich bezahlt?
Und selbst wenn, also ich bin nicht bezahlbar diesbezüglich. Das macht man nicht. Und der simple Grund ist, das ist Werbung und Werbung, das wollen die, indem sie das bezahlen, aber Werbung hat damit oder hat darin nichts verloren. Schwierig wird es dann, und da sind wir wieder bei der Zuschauerverträglichkeit, wenn ein Stadion wie das Emirates nicht mehr anders zu betiteln ist. Dann wird es schwierig. Bei Manchester im Etihad, Manchester City, versuche ich noch immer ab und zu aufs KOMS auszuweichen, das glaube ich versteht man noch, aber du machst natürlich Felder auf, du führst Leute hinter die Fichte, die dann vielleicht irgendwie googeln müssen oder irgendwie anders. Das ist dann auch nicht gut. Da muss man dann eben auch sagen im Sinne des Zuschauers.
Vorschlag zur Güte, ich würde sagen, immer da, wo der Sponsorname zu präsent ist, immer die Bezeichnung nehmen, die es bei Pro Evolution Soccer gibt.
Nee, Anhalt, Anhalt. Passend zu Fritz von Ton und Taxis irgendwie in meinem Kopf. Bayern München hieß damals Anhalt.
So, wir haben noch zwei sportliche Fragen. Wobei, bei der zweiten bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie viel Sport damit gemeint ist, denn die Eintracht Frankfurt kommt vor. Deswegen fangen wir mit der ersten an. Wir haben jetzt schon über so ein bisschen negative Überraschungen gesprochen. Hast du jemanden auf der Liste, wo du sagst, das könnte die positive Überraschung in der nächsten Bundesligasaison werden? Hier wird lautstraft Eintracht Braunschweig gefordert.
Ja, mir gefällt der Weg, den die Frankfurter in den letzten zwei Jahren mit Kobra gegangen sind. Das ist ein bisschen wie beim Doppelpass. Ich hätte es auch gesagt, wenn ich da hinten sitzen würde. Weil da für mich mal wieder zur Kenntnis, dass jemand installiert wird, der eine Idee hat, der eine Vorstellung hat, dem Macht gegeben wird. Also im gewissen Rahmen. Und dieser Weg wird verfolgt und zwar konsequent. Auch wenn es nicht immer der allerschönste Fußball ist, aber es ist eine Philosophie dahinter zu erkennen. Ich glaube einfach, dass sich das jetzt so weiterentwickelt. Und wenn sie es schaffen, ein bisschen ihre Abhängigkeit von Alex Meyer, der jetzt auch schon in der letzten Saison das eine oder andere Mal gefehlt hat, sich davon ein bisschen zu lösen und ein paar Alternativen aufs Feld zu bringen, kann es interessant werden. Die Frage ist im Kontext einfach, Frankfurt, was ist da eine Überraschung? Ist Euro League eine Überraschung? Wäre Champions League Quali eine Überraschung? Auf jeden Fall alles, was irgendwie einstellig ist. Und ansonsten eher weniger. Danach kommt relativ wenig.
Basti, komm außen rum, dann darfst du die Frage gleich stellen. Und währenddessen darf Uli mir noch seine positive Überraschung der nächsten monosige Saison nennen.
Gemessen an dem, dass sie nicht viel verbessern müssen im Vergleich zur letzten Saison, glaube ich, Stuttgart könnte funktionieren. Ist Hoffenheim noch eine Überraschung? Wahrscheinlich eher weniger. Für Stuttgart wäre es ja schon fast eine Überraschung, wenn sie irgendwie einstellig enden. Und das ist schon drin, glaube ich. Also noch dazu, die haben ja noch so 10 Millionen übrig. Haben eine ganz gute Idee, wenn sie damit verpflichten könnten. Haben, glaube ich, inzwischen ein einigermaßen stabiles Umfeld, wenn auch der eine oder andere behauptet, egobehaftet. Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Schindelmeiser jetzt schon wieder in der Kritik, aber das will ich jetzt nicht auf meine eigene Vorschau vorausgreifen. Wir haben eine Publikumsfrage bekommen von einer Stimme, die euch allen als Podcast-Hörerinnen und Hörern durchaus bekannt sein sollte. Er ist bei 93 zu hören, ist im Eintritt Frankfurt, Podcast zu hören. Er ist nicht zu übersehen, weder bei Twitter noch in eurem Podcatcher. Der großartige Basti Red.
Ja, ich setze mich wahrscheinlich jetzt in die Nesseln, weil ich die Frage an den falschen Spieler stelle. Die Sache ist die, wir haben oft diskutiert und wir haben oft Pro und Contra bekommen beim Altra-Podcast bei 93, weil ich vertrete die Meinung, dass wenn ich Fußballer wäre, dann würde ich zum Beispiel nicht nach Ingolstadt wechseln und ich würde auch – nein, nein, nein, so war das gar nicht gemein. Hallo, nein, ich will nur fragen – Er hat was an Pauli geschrieben. Ja eben, und das ist ja meine Frage jetzt. Leute, ganz bitte ruhig jetzt. Die Sache ist, ich will nur wissen, weil ich oft die These vertrete, es gibt Leute wie Tobias Escher, die analysieren den Fußball auf sehr rationale Weise. Und ich bin jemand, der den Fußball eher auf emotionale Weise analysiert. Mich würde es interessieren, ob es für den Spieler wirklich, und bitte nehmen nicht alle meine Illusionen, eine Rolle spielt, ob du vor 5000 oder vor 50 Außerszenen spielst.
Grundsätzlich eine sehr, sehr legitime Frage. Jetzt kommt es aber, und versteht mich bitte nicht falsch. Für mich ist Fußball was anderes als für dich. Du bist der Fan einer Mannschaft. Du hast eine enge Verbindung, du hast eine emotionale Verbindung zu einem Verein. Die hatte ich auch in meiner Jugend. Ich bin auch in Mannschaften hinterher gefahren, stand in der Kurve, stand am Bus, wollte Autogramme. Das ganze Spiel, was ihr wahrscheinlich in eurer Kindheit und Jugend auch hattet, jetzt ein bisschen vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so Fanboy-mäßig, aber die emotionale Bindung ist da. Mit 17 kam bei mir aber der Turn zum Profi. Und dann musst du das alles beiseite schieben, weil dann wird es der Beruf. Und das ist was völlig anderes. Und du kannst mir glauben, ich hatte eine schöne Zeit in Ingolstadt, wenn ich es mir hätte aussuchen können, wäre ich ja aber noch fünf Jahre beim FC St. Pauli geblieben. Aber zu solchen Wechseln gehören immer zwei Leute oder zwei Parteien. Weil wenn der Verein zu dir kommt und sagt, war schön, aber jetzt brauchen wir dich nicht mehr, dann guckst du, was du machen kannst. So, und ich stand zu dem Zeitpunkt, die Situation war folgende. Mein Vertrag lief noch sechs Monate, ich bin im Winter gewechselt, mein Vertrag lief noch sechs Monate, und man hat mir relativ unmissverständlich klargemacht, dass meine Zeit nach acht Jahren vorbei ist. Man hat zwei neue Innenverteidiger geholt, wir waren sowieso schon fünf, ich habe kaum von Anfang an gespielt, und dann stehst du da, willst noch Fußball spielen, darfst aber nicht mehr. Und hast nicht mehr viele Möglichkeiten, natürlich. Mein erstes Auswärtsspiel mit dem FC Ingolstadt war bei FSV Frankfurt mit 2300 Zuschauern, Freitagsabends. Wenn du jetzt mit dem FC St. Pauli irgendwo hinkommst, dann ist auch die – wie heißt die Arena mittlerweile – Volksbank? Genau. Das Ding ist halt voll. Dann bin ich nach Ingolstadt gewechselt. Ich weiß natürlich, dass das ein Kulturschock war. Trotzdem war das für mich dann wieder eine neue Aufgabe, eine sehr interessante Aufgabe. Und wenn jetzt einer kommt, ja, Werksverein und Zahlen, blablabla. Ich habe weniger verdient als mit dem FC St. Pauli. Und natürlich spiele ich lieber vor 25.000, 30.000. Aber ich kann es mir nicht aussuchen. Nein, ganz kurz.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das Problem war, dass du eben neben mir saßt und ich Ingolstadt benutzt habe. Es ging gar nicht darum. Ich wollte einfach nur wissen. Weil die Sache ist die, jeder, der mich kennt und mich bei 93 hört, weiß ganz genau, ich würde noch viel schneller nach Ingolstadt wechseln, als du, wenn du mir mehr Geld zahlen würdest. Nein, aber das sollte keine Kritik sein, sondern ich wollte nur wissen, ob, wenn ich auswärts stehe, in Gladbach zum Beispiel, die Eintracht zieht in Gladbach, die Eintracht zieht in Gladbach in das CPEB-Kallfinerlein, da stehen 6.000, 7.000 Leute und wir feiern das. Und Herr Gotthard läuft nach dem entscheidenden Elfmeter auf uns zu. Ich wollte nur wissen, ob die Spieler in dem Moment, ab denen das wirklich was bedeutet, oder ob einem das überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Ja, das interessiert uns definitiv, nur du musst das dann ein bisschen den Törn kriegen von der sehr emotionalen Sicht, die du als Fan natürlich hast, zu der professionellen Sicht und zur professionellen Verbindung zu dem Job, den wir haben. Es wird immer gesprochen über Gérard, über Totti, über Maldini und die Jungs, die 12, 14, 15, 18 Jahre in einem Verein gespielt haben. Warum? Wohin soll denn Gérard wechseln? Wohin sollen Totti wechseln? Die spielen bei Top-Vereinen. Die haben alles. Ich kenne so viele Leute, und dazu gehöre ich auch, die irgendwann mal irgendwo wegmusten, nicht weil sie wollten, sondern sie mussten. Bestes Beispiel, aktuell. Was haben alle über David Selke gestimpft? Wie kann der nach Leipzig gehen? Söldner und und und. Wisst ihr, was dahinter steckt? Dahinter steckt Werder Bremen, weil die sagten, du musst gehen, wir brauchen acht Millionen. Und das durfte aber nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gelangen. Ganz kurz, Davy wollte in Bremen bleiben. Es geht darum, dass du auf der Spieler-Ebene eine ganz andere Beziehung zu diesem ganzen Geschäft hast, weil es gezwungenermaßen der Fall ist. Und natürlich spielen wir lieber vor einem 20.000-Auswärts-Block. Aber das können wir uns nicht immer aussuchen.
Aber das meint ihr dann?
Jeder spielt doch. Ich habe es auch nicht als Kritik empfunden. Ich wollte es dir tatsächlich nur aufzeigen, dass auf Spielerseite sehr viel mehr dazukommt, als nur die Stimme. Ich hätte nach meiner Zeit in Mainz nicht mehr bei Eintracht unterschrieben. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so eine Geschichte. Das weiß ich zum Beispiel auch von vielen Spielern, die gewisse Prinzipien haben. Die sagen, ich habe mal bei einem Verein gespielt, und weil ich bei diesem Verein gespielt habe, fallen automatisch zwei, drei Vereine aus dem Raster.
Viel mehr darüber werdet ihr erfahren. Am Mittwoch bist du im Millerntum-Podcast zu Gast.
Richtig, da sprechen wir auch darüber.
Und es könnte sein, dass es sogar bald noch ein Tribünengespräch in ruhigerer Atmosphäre gibt. Vielleicht lade ich aber alle auch wieder ein.
Ja, genau. Kommt alle dazu.
Und dann können wir alle das nochmal genauer besprechen. Uli, Ralph, ich möchte euch sehr herzlich danken. Ihr wart ganz herausragende Gäste unter äußerst schwierigen Bedingungen. Ich danke sehr dem Kommentator bei DAZN. Bei Twitter heißt er etUliHebel, folgt ihm. Uli Hebel. Und außerdem herzlichen Dank. Wir konnten jetzt nicht über Auto sprechen. Mein eigentliches Lieblingsthema, das tut mir sehr leid. Das holen wir dann nach im Felgenfunk. Vielen Dank. Es gibt jetzt die Los Rallos-Woches. Was damit gemeint ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, werdet ihr in einer Woche erfahren haben. Vielen Dank an Ralph Gunesch et Felgenrelle. Danke dir. Und damit danke ich auch euch sehr für die Aufmerksamkeit. Hört den Rasenfunk und alle anderen Podcasts, die es gibt. Rasenfunk.de slash-Portrol ist die wichtigste Internetadresse, denn da gibt es all die hervorragenden Fußball-Podcasts, die Deutschland so zu bieten hat und auch Teile der restlichen Welt. Aber wir sind hier in Bayern ehrlich gesagt zäh da. Ich danke euch fürs Zuhören. Herzlichen.
Das war das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.